three years ago today market and Bowman
our city and the world will never forget
the Las Vegas Strip and all other
non-essential businesses closed due to
the covid-19 pandemic it was really a
historic moment that touched everyone's
lives and some say after all this time
things finally feel normal again Sasha
Loftus joining us live from the strip
with more tonight hi Sasha
good evening Brian this is the Las Vegas
Strip we're all used to right it's
crowded it's fun exciting and at times a
little crazy but three years ago marked
a much darker day those I spoke with
tonight say they're glad it's back to
the way things were before
see everybody out and about and getting
their Irish on St Patrick's Day in Las
Vegas people piling in mean green and
ready to party
it was just so eerie but exactly three
years ago it was a much different
picture you're being told not to go out
you are being told not to go out on
March 17 2020 former Governor Steve
sisalak ordered all non-essential
businesses to close turning the normally
bustling Las Vegas strip in Fremont
Street into a ghost town it was very
surreal and almost creepy to see all of
the buildings down here boarded up and
no vibrancy at all Kim Owens opened her
downtown restaurant Main Street
Provisions just a few months later and
she says the stress and restrictions
made the process anything but easy 25
capacity six feet between tables limit
of four guests per table Shane like many
others struggled to stay afloat but
Owens tells me the work was worth it
because this year her business is
thriving I feel like perhaps we are on
track as to where I thought we would be
in 2020 when we opened it has taken a
long time but so many say they're glad
to finally see our city back on top it's
an eye opening compared to what it used
to be
now you remember the strip stay closed
for about three months it reopened on
June 4th 2020. now according to the
lvcva our tourism industry lost about 34
billion dollars that year reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now